There's more and more attention being paid
to Joe Biden seemingly struggling to remember
basic facts and saying strange things of Joe
Biden.
In the video.
I'm going to play for you today.
Seems to forget Barack Obama's name and instead
refers to him as the guy that I worked for.
Now I know that there are some people in my
audience who are going to write in very mad
saying, David, you are perpetuating these
conspiracy theories about Biden.
The truth is, if I don't talk about this at
this point, I'm a hypocrite.
Okay.
When Donald Trump missteps and appears to
be cognitively compromised, I talk about it
because it's serious.
The president's cognitive abilities and the
cognitive state of the president is one of
the most important things and figuring out
is this person even competent to potentially
be president of the United States.
With Hillary Clinton, there was a ton of fake
stuff.
Hillary has Parkinson's.
Hillary's on her deathbed, she, she will be
dead within months of being inaugurated if
we elect our president of the United States.
It was both bogus conspiracy stuff and I didn't
cover it with Trump.
We've had the slurring speech, trouble reading,
sniffing confusion, going to a, an executive
order signing and then leaving without signing
anything walking off of Air Force One and
his limo is right in front of him and he wanders
off and has to be brought back saying that
he wants to look into the oranges of an investigation
multiple times, unable to just say, I want
to look into the origins of the investigation.
I've covered it because it's extremely concerning.
Uh, Joe Biden is also seeming a bit off.
Let's look at video from a fundraiser again
this week where he seems to forget Barack
Obama's name
because they invaded another country and an
extra significant portion of the call.
Crimea.
He's saying that it was president, my boss,
it was his fault.
Now I get that anyone can forget a word or
a name at any time.
I get that.
But this sort of strange thing, especially
when you just look at Biden today and over
the last few months versus the Biden of 2012
when he debated and crushed Paul Ryan, for
example, I said after both of the debates
this year that Biden seemed slowed down.
He seemed low energy.
He seemed not quick on his feet.
If you go back and look at video of when Joe
Biden debated Paul, the much younger, by the
way, Paul Ryan back in 2012 Biden was quick.
He was sharp.
He was running circles around Paul Ryan.
Paul Ryan didn't stand a chance.
I mean, just literally embarrassed Paul Ryan.
He seemed different.
And, uh, if I ignored this now, I would be
a hypocrite because I do have questions about
this.
This is not anything to make fun of.
There's nothing to make fun of about Donald
Trump's possible cognitive decline.
It's not a joke.
We want to be sure that the person who is
the president or someone who might be president
is fully there cognitively, period.
I've never seen anything like this with Bernie
Sanders.
I've never seen anything like this with Elizabeth
Warren.
She's younger.
It doesn't matter.
The point is it's the behavior that we should
be talking about.
This is not about political party.
This is not about a, a, anything like that.
I don't know what to make of this and I'm
curious to hear from you about it.
What do you think about what's going on here
with Joe Biden?
Are there now enough examples of this that
it rises to a level where we should be asking
more questions and be concerned?
I want to hear from you.